hey 42 here over the years we've all
done crazy things for love maybe you've
written a valentine's day poem perhaps
you've taken your partner to see her
favorite film knowing you're going to
hate it or maybe you bought some flowers
that weren't from the petrol station
whilst you might think you've gone above
and beyond in the name of love i'm
afraid these trivial gestures are
nothing compared to the acts of a man
so deeply in love even death couldn't
stand in his way
this is the genuinely terrifying story
of karl tanzler and the corpse bride
[Music]
now i'd like to take a minute to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their twenties
and it's always been an upsetting
experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left personally i like
keeps because it makes treatment super
easy
by delivering your hair loss medication
every three months straight to your door
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in pharmacy checkout
lines there's a really good reason that
keeps has more 5 star reviews than any
of its competitors and hundreds of
thousands of men trust them for their
hair loss prevention medication
so if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
42 or click the link in the description
below to receive 50 off your first order
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this
video don't forget to try it out using
the link below
carl was born in dresden germany in
1877. and from what we know about him he
lived an entirely uneventful childhood
that is until he turned 12 when one
night he was visited by one of his
ancestors in a dream
this long dead relative was kind enough
to show carl the face of his one true
love
a beautiful foreigner with dark hair
by the time carl woke up in the morning
he knew that was the woman he would
spend the rest of his life with
the only trouble was
he didn't know where to find her
in the end it would be more than 40
years before he finally stumbled across
this literal girl of his dreams
during the intervening years carl became
a man travelled the world and even got
married to a woman named doris schaefer
the couple had two children together but
fond as carl was of his wife
he could never quite shake his
disappointment that she wasn't that
dark-haired beauty once promised to him
in a dream
in 1926 he and his family emigrated to
the united states to start a new life in
florida and it was there that carl's
general dissatisfaction with how his
life had turned out came to a head
he needed a new start so he pretty much
abandoned his family and took a new job
as a radiology technician at a hospital
in key west rebranding himself count
carl von kosel it was in the april of
1930 that the weird stuff started to
happen
one day a woman was brought into the
hospital for an examination that's not
the weird bit i mean it was a hospital
but as soon as carl got a glimpse of the
girl he knew her at once
a beautiful foreigner with dark hair
she was the girl from his childhood
dream
as far as carl was concerned his
soulmate had just conveniently stepped
into his place of work
and boy would she regret it
maria elena malagro de hoya who for
obvious reasons just went by eleanor was
a 21 year old cuban if this was a
classic rom-com she would be rachel
mcadams to tanzler's hugh grant
she was technically married but her
husband had left her as she had suffered
a miscarriage
and if i'm being completely honest i
don't think her relationship status was
all of that much interest to karl
tanzler he couldn't care less as she was
separated in a loving marriage a widow
or one of those strange americans you
hear about who marries their car
he wanted her and he was going to have
her even if he did happen to be 32 years
her senior there was admittedly one of a
small problem with this plan
elena hadn't been admitted to hospital
for a run-of-the-mill checkup
she had tuberculosis which considering
the lack of an available cure in those
days was basically a death sentence even
today tb remains one of the world's
leading causes of death claiming 1.5
million lives in 2020.
carl was understandably devastated but
despite not really knowing all that much
about tb or you know actually being a
doctor he made it his life's mission to
save elena he immediately began
experimenting with various tonics and
concoctions in the hopes that he'd
stumble across a cure
with the permission of eleanor's family
carl began administering these
treatments in their home which was soon
full of various gadgets that he'd
managed to steal from the hospital
now so far karl tanzler might not sound
like all that much of a bad guy i mean
he was doing everything in his power to
try and save eleanor
even if some of his methods were a
little
unconventional
if he'd stopped there history probably
would have remembered him as a misguided
and medically irresponsible dreamer
rather than an utter psychopath
but
yeah he didn't stop there
not even close despite carl's best
efforts eleanor died in october 1931.
he was so devastated he offered to pay
for the funeral and for an expensive
mausoleum in key west cemetery
her family saw it as a kind gesture
but in reality it should have been a
massive red flag because little did they
know carl would keep hold of the
mausoleum's only key
and this is where our richard curtis
romcom
meets tim burton
for more than a year tonsler visited
eleanor's grave every single night
he would sit by her coffin
chatting away as though eleanor still
lived
if anything his death only seemed to
have increased his devotion
but then all of a sudden
the visit stopped
in hindsight that should have been
another red flag but i guess helena's
family simply assumed carl tunzler had
finally moved on
of course there was only one other
reason he would have stopped visiting
eleanor's grave
if she wasn't in it anymore
according to carl himself elena's spirit
had appeared to him and asked to be
taken back to his house
not one to take the words of the dead
lightly as we've already seen
one night in april 1933 carl removed
eleanor's body from its resting place
and brought it home with him
he'd been told he'd marry this woman and
he wasn't going to let a silly little
thing like death stand in his way
there were of course a few logistical
issues with carl's new relationship
status
elena had been dead for 18 months and
she was aging like a mr whippy in the
sahara in an effort to stem the decay
karl built a makeshift lab in his house
and then he got to work
he stabilized the body's shape with coat
hangers and wires and stuffed a torso
with rags to fill things out a little
he applied mortician's wax to the face
and fashioned a wig out of what remained
of her hair
he even replaced her eyes with glass
orbs
tonsler disinfected the body regularly
and that's along with liberal use of
strong perfumes
went some way towards masking his new
bride's unfortunate odor
by the time he was finished tonsler's
dream had finally come true and for the
first time in his life he was truly
happy with all the enthusiasm of a
newlywed he spent almost every moment of
every day with eleanor's corpse he sat
it at the dinner table whilst he ate
danced with it in the living room and
even laid the body beside him in bed as
he slept
hopefully
of course all his actions soon began to
produce inevitable signs of wear and
tear on tanzler's new wife
to make matters even worse what remained
of eleanor's body was slowly rotting
away to nothing
apparently dating an actual skeleton was
too much even for carl tanzler so he
replaced elena's skin with silk cloth
coated in wax and plaster of paris
essentially building himself a human
doll made from bits of real human
somehow this absolutely bat-shit insane
situation continued for about seven
years without anybody noticing
meaning eleanor had been dead for almost
nine years this is the part in our
classic rom-com where you walk out of
the cinema because it's disgusting
but it turns out carl didn't want things
to go on this way forever you see over
the years he'd been working on a
strategy to bring his wife back to life
for good
the plan basically involved building a
rocket and launching elena's dead body
into space
where he hoped radiation would restore
her to the land of the living
which admittedly was a tad ambitious
but hey
in the end carl never got to find out
whether this ingenious plan would have
worked
though i'm prepared to go out on a limb
here and say it probably wouldn't have
rumors were beginning to spread around
key west about that weird old man who
lived alone and hardly left his house
except to buy women's clothes and
suspiciously large quantities of perfume
one day a local boy passing the house
happened to see carl dancing with what
looked like a large doll in the living
room i suppose we can't really blame him
for not immediately suspecting carl was
living with a nine-year-old corpse but
anyway
others were growing suspicious too
particularly eleanor's sister florinda
who perhaps unsurprisingly had never
been carl's biggest fan
with his story now the talk of the town
florinda paid carl a visit in 1940 and
it's safe to say she was shocked by what
she found
the nine-year-old remained of her sister
in a dress
the authorities were immediately alerted
and carl was arrested
an autopsy soon uncovered the full
disturbing details of the horrific
makeover
including certain
modifications carl had made to
facilitate the consummation of his
marriage to eleanor
yeah this is the part in our classic
rom-com where it gets banned from
netflix for being too graphic
despite taking a dead body to his house
living with it
loving it and planning to shoot it into
space a psychiatric evaluation actually
deemed carl tanzler to be mentally
competent enough to stand trial
he faced the charges of maliciously
destroying a grave and removing the body
without authorization
but in perhaps the biggest shock of this
whole story the case against carl was
dropped
and he served not a single day of
present time
not because he wasn't very obviously
guilty but because the statute of
limitations had expired for his offence
as a result carl tunsler was free to go
and he even received quite a lot of
positive press coverage and public
support
as many people at the time saw his
actions as just plain old romantic
people were weird in the old days
in one final twist to this strange
gruesome story
poor old eleanor's body wasn't
reinterred after finally being rescued
from carl's clutches
but put on display at a funeral home
the story was big news and thousands of
people lined up to get a look at her
including carl tunzler himself rumor has
it he'd even asked the authorities if he
could have the body returned to him as
you can probably imagine the request was
denied after interest in the case died
down eleanor was finally laid to rest
once more
this time at a secret location just in
case carl got any ideas
[Music]
in later life tanzler received u.s
citizenship and wrote an autobiography
oh and do you remember doris
that wife he had before any of this
weirdness happened
you know the mother of his children that
he walked out on
well they remained friends
you'd think it would be awkward what
with him fancying a dead body more than
her and all that but apparently not
and she even supported him financially
in his later years
i'm sure carl was grateful but he never
gave up on his one true love
when he died in 1952 his body was found
with a life-sized doll
that bore a striking resemblance to his
corpse bride
it's been suggested by some that carl
somehow found out where the real eleanor
was buried and switched to body with a
fake
but there's no real evidence to support
that story and as the credits roll on
our awful rom-com i have to say it's
much more likely that it was indeed just
a doll
either way
carl tanzler's life is surely the
weirdest love story never told
and a useful reminder of how not to take
a girl out
[Music]
thanks for watching